Nikki Haley beat Donald Trump among
Independents by something like 40 V you
know 40 percentage points Joy Reed over
on
MSNBC uh she said something kind of sane
here if New Hampshire is the avatar for
what independent voters want and would
choose uh you know given the option
given the fact that anyone could play in
that independent side uh Nikki Haley
beat Donald Trump among Independents by
something like 40 V you know 40
percentage points that is not a good
sign for a sitting former a former
president of the United States who again
wants to be seen as president yes he
will beat her in South Carolina but
let's not forget that one of the things
that Joe Biden did was to remake the
calendar such that he was not on the
ballot in New Hampshire still mopped up
Dean Phillips in New Hampshire when he
wasn't even on the ballot as a right in
candidate yes Donald Trump will likely
win South Carolina Nikki Haley's home
state Joe Biden might win it by more
because that state is built for Joe
Biden just like on the Republican side
it's built for Donald Trump so tonight
the winner if you want to look at all of
the metrics for a general election the
winner tonight is Joe Biden who won in
New Hampshire decisively as a r in who
is going to win decisively in South
Carolina and the story that Donald Trump
thinks he's going to get out of South
Carolina Joe Biden will get one of equal
value to him uh and in the end he's got
a better story to tell in November cuz
he not facing 91 criminal counts let me
let me ask okay I can't believe it but I
am going to say that that is actually
somewhat sane analysis by Joy Reed so I
guess it could happen once a year or
maybe once a decade or something like
that but as I was referencing before
this idea of the crossover people
supporting Nikki it shows you that the
crossover people do not want Trump so
that her argument then is oh so that is
a victory for Biden because if Trump is
the nominee and it looks like Trump will
be the nominee the crossover people at
least in New Hampshire will end up
voting for Joe Biden and not for Donald
Trump So to that end it is a victory for
Joe Biden I don't know that you can make
much of an argument against that I
cannot believe this are we in bizar land
I'm doing this show from bizar land did
I have a stroke what the hell's going on
here we're giving Joy Reed credit it's
really really wild it's also worth
noting that because the Democrats are so
freaking deeply corrupt they did not put
Joe Biden on the ballot so if you if you
CAU those numbers there at the end Joe
Biden got about 20,000 votes it didn't
even matter right they were right in
votes and then Dean Phillips he's a
congressman from uh from Minnesota he
got what was it 6,000 votes something
like that and then Maryann Williamson I
can't believe she's still at it with her
crystals she got about a thousand votes
uh but I do think that Joy Reed's
analysis is kind of right that the
crossover people are making it clear
that they don't like Donald Trump now
maybe they'll never vote for Republican
so it doesn't matter but I think that
there's some there's just something if
you're watching this and you're you're
going you know I like Dave again because
he's supporting Trump and it is what it
is you should still be aware of the
reality uh on the
ground